Katrin Eigendorf ist für das ZDF in Kiew
und auch heute Abend in dieser Sendung
Katrin gestern vorgestern möchte man
sagen saßen die Menschen noch in den
Straßencafés und
seit Dienstag sieht das ganz anders aus
wie kommen die Menschen klar mit dieser
Angst wenn sie in den Himmel schauen
sehr schlecht also ich erlebe Kiew
wirklich in einer Ausnahmesituation
es ist einfach so man muss sich
vorstellen muss ich das vorstellen wenn
wir jetzt durch Berlin gehen würden und
müssten jederzeit damit rechnen dass
vielleicht auf dem Kudamm oder irgendwo
im Tiergarten Raketen einschlagen was
das für ein Gefühl ist das hat die
Menschen mitten im Herzen der Stadt
erwischt es hat im Prinzip ganz
unterschiedliche Menschen erwischt also
eine junge Frau die eine fünfjährige
Tochter hinterlässt ein Ehepaar so viele
Menschen sind hier einfach mitten aus
dem Leben gerissen worden auch sehr
viele schwer verletzt worden das hat
schon für Angst gesorgt aber ich sehe in
Kiew auch trotz aller Angst und
Verzweiflung die das erzeugt hat eine
große Entschlossenheit also noch einmal
dass die Menschen sagen wir werden nicht
zurückweichen wir werden uns nicht
einschüchtern lassen im Prinzip hat
Putin durch diese Angriffe noch einmal
für die Ukraine ganz klar gemacht was
das eigentlich für ein Regime ist und
das ist ja die größte Angst der Ukrainer
weswegen sie hier auch so so sehr
eintreten dass ihr Land von Russland
irgendwann übernommen werden kann
besetzt werden kann also
deswegen es hat sicherlich sehr viel
Verzweiflung erzeugt viele Tragödien die
wir hier erleben aber dennoch erlebe ich
die Menschen sehr entschlossen hier
weiter Widerstand zu leisten ein
bleibender Schaden ist an der
Infrastruktur entstanden seit diesem
Bombardement seit dem 10.10 30 Prozent
sollen getroffen sein wie kommen die
Ukraine über den Winter denken sie
das wird an eine große Herausforderung
und ein großes Problem das ist ja nur in
Kiew so dass hier relativ wenig
Infrastruktur getroffen wurde und auch
hier haben wir schon eine Situation wo
mittlerweile in bestimmten Stadtteilen
nur noch stundenweise dann Strom zur
Verfügung steht aber ich war letzte
Woche noch in haakev im Osten der
Ukraine in einigen der befreiten Städte
und Dörfer und da ist es so dass da fast
die gesamte Infrastruktur zerstört ist
ich frage mich wirklich wie die Leute da
weiterleben wollen denn sie haben ja
keine funktionierenden Häuser mehr die
sind teilweise wirklich bis auf die
Grundmauern liegen die in Schutt und
Asche und selbst wenn sie noch stehen
dann funktionieren Heizungen nicht mehr
Leitungen sind beschädigt die gesamte
Infrastruktur auch was Krankenhäuser
Schulen Kindergärten angeht nichts
funktioniert mehr da und um es immer
einfach konkret zu machen ich habe dann
zum Beispiel letzte Woche in Liman mit
Menschen angesprochen zum Beispiel mit
zwei Frauen etwas ältere die beide im
Krankenhaus gearbeitet haben und die
eine sagte mir ich leide unter Diabetes
ich habe nur noch für einen Monat
Medikamente was was werde ich machen
hier kommt nichts mehr an also es ist
ein wirklich dramatischer
Versorgungsengpass dafür die Menschen
entstanden und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen wie es die Ukraine schaffen
soll ja in diesem Winter so viele Leute
einfach ja den jetzt wieder eine
Struktur zu bieten weil gleichzeitig
befindet sich das Land ja auch dauerhaft
im Krieg und die Angriffe gehen ja jetzt
weiter
das ist eine fatale Situation wir wollen
versuchen zu klären wie sehr das eine
neue Strategie Putins ist Margarete ist
klein ist bei uns Russland Expertin
Politikwissenschaftlerin wie stark steht
und stand Putin in den letzten Wochen ob
seiner Misserfolge an der Front unter
Druck jetzt irgendetwas anderes tun zu
müssen frau Klein
er macht ja im Moment nichts großartiges
anderes eskaliert auf verschiedenen
Ebenen aber es steht unter Druck denn
dieses putinische Regime legitimiert
sich sehr stark mit der Demonstration
aus dem politischer Größe und Erfolge
und den wirtschaftlichen Pfeiler gibt es
schon lange nicht mehr Verteilung von
Wohltaten in weite Teile der Bevölkerung
wenn jetzt dieser Pfeiler der der Größe
Demonstration nach außen wegfällt ist es
wirklich schwierig für dieses Regime
also versucht man zu eskalieren und wir
sehen das ja auch verschiedenen Ebenen
das ist angesprochen worden humanitäre
Situation in der Ukraine teilmobil
machen und die de facto in der General
mobil machen Stille übergeführt werden
kann weil es keine Obergrenzen gibt und
die klar signalisiert dass dieser Krieg
weitergehen soll über eine längere Zeit
und das dritte ist natürlich dann eben
auch die proklamierte Annexion dieser
vier ukrainischen Regionen die man ja
zum Teil überhaupt aus der oberen muss
da dieses Gebiet dass man da erklärt
erklärt hat zu annektieren ist er noch
gar nicht vollständig erobert das heißt
da muss man auch eskalieren und dann
kommt noch die nukleare Drohung
obendrauf die letztendlich die Ukraine
abschrecken soll diese Gebiete zu
befreien und den Westen von weiterer
militärunterstützung abhalten soll und
das alles ist so eine so eine
Eskalationsspirale in ganz verschiedenen
Dimensionen ist es auch ein Zeichen an
die Hardliner in Moskau um deutlich zu
machen die ich in denen gewachsen das
ist ein Zeichen die Hardliner sind
offener herausgekommen werden vokaler
sozusagen stimmgewaltiger auch die
Ernennung von sudovicin als
Oberbefehlshaber ist ein klares
Zugeständnis kadyroof und pregorien der
Chef der wagnergruppierung haben sehr
klar Front gemacht gegen den
Verteidigungsminister der an sich früher
eine sehr große Popularität hatte
weil er eben angeblich inkompetent sei
und deswegen versucht man hier eine
harte Position die auf maximale
Eskalation setzt Ben Hodges ist bei uns
ehemaliger General der us-amerikan des
us-am medizinischen Heeres hier in
Europa
die Experten sagen Russland gehen die
modernen Raketen aus
ist das Teil der Strategie oder ist es
ein riesen Wagnis was Putin da am Ende
begeht
ihm gehen wirklich die Präzisionswaffen
aus die Sanktionen machen es für
Russland unmöglich diese
Präzisionswaffen die sie da verwenden zu
ersetzen und deswegen verwenden Sie
jetzt luftabwehrwaffen gegen Wohnhäuser
die Strategie verändert sich dadurch für
Sie denn die Vorgänger auf dem Boden
sind einfach katastrophal das ist ein
Fehlschlag in jeder Facette und die
Flotte in der Schwaben Schwarzen Meer
versteckt sich ob schon die Ukraine
keine meeresstreitkräfte hat das heißt
es wird jetzt versucht den Krieg zu
verlängern damit wir unsere Geduld und
unsere Willenskraft langsam aber sicher
verlieren denn die Unterstützung des
Westens ist wirklich der Schwerpunkt für
die Ukraine und deswegen versucht Putin
diesen Konflikt einfach so weit wie
möglich hinaus zu strecken wir haben
vorgestellt bekommen Serge serowogen den
neuen Kommandeur der Russen der aus
Syrien bekannt ist und als generell
einmal geht dann bezeichnet wurde
ich steht das zu befürchten im
Hinterland der Ukraine dass man nun
städtebombardiert wie einst alle
ja
das steht zu befürchten er ist
ausgewählt worden bei der zwei
Qualitäten mitbringt nämlich Brutalität
und Loyalität und ich glaube dass Putin
und ich möchte ja Markus natürlich nicht
widersprechen aber ich denke das Poti
sich zuerst einmal nicht Sorgen um die
Generäle sondern um ihre Loyalität macht
und deswegen hat er sich jetzt mit
Menschen wie vergorian und
carriereformen geben und jetzt dieser
neue General von dem er sicher sein kann
dass er loyal bleiben wird und ich denke
dass die Menschen die Putin umgeben
jetzt langsam aber sicher verstehen was
für eine Katastrophe das eigentlich ist
in der sie sich da befinden also noch
einmal er wird versuchen diesen Konflikt
in die Länge zu ziehen mit diesen
Raketen und jetzt hat er den richtigen
Kommandeur dafür bevor ich auch mit
nuripur Frage ist ist vielleicht eine
gute Frage gleich an Gregor Gysi den aus
dem politischen Sprecher der Linken herr
Gysi sie sind strikt dagegen dass man
der der Ukraine auch schwere Waffen
liefert würden sie in diesem konkreten
Fall wo jetzt Zivilisten bombardiert
werden eine Ausnahme machen und sagen
das überschreitet auch meine Grenze und
unsere politische nein ich bin nur
dagegen dass Deutschland warten liefert
ich bin nicht generell gegen
Waffenlieferung die Ukraine hat ein
Selbstverteidigungsrecht wir haben nur
eine andere Geschichte als andere Länder
von Deutschland gegen der schlimmste
Krieg der Menschheitsgeschichte aus der
Zweite Weltkrieg mit 50 Millionen Toten
und deshalb dürfen wir nicht mehr einen
kriegen verdienen ich sag mal ein
Beispiel aus der heutigen Debatte da
ging es darum dass die Bundesregierung
einschließlich der Grünen zugestimmt
haben Waffenlieferung von 39 Millionen
Euro an Saudi-Arabien die Krieg führen
in je mit schon 400.000 Toten wir
verdienen an dem Krieg ich möchte nicht
dass wir einen kriegen verdienen wir
haben Hitler hervorgebracht die anderen
haben gegen ihn gekämpft die haben
andere Geschichte die Ukraine allen
voran nein und deshalb sage ich ja und
deshalb sage ich Frankreich
Großbritannien USA könnte eine andere
Politik machen als Deutschland wir
sollten statt Button den gleichen um
liefern aber humanitäre Hilfe und wenn
ich habe euch anschreibe und für den
Vorort von Kiew der zerstört war das hat
mir imponiert bei den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern dass sie gleich wieder
aufbauen die bauen gleich wieder auf
warten nicht bis zum Ende des Krieges
und da habe ich Betonmischer und Traktor
Busse angefordert sagt er dafür ist kein
Geld und keine Strukturen da also nur
verwaffen das ist mir zu einseitig und
deshalb habe ich also meine Äußerung auf
Waffen bezieht sich immer auf
Deutschland nicht etwa generell sie
finden generell dass die Ukraine sich
verteidigen kann und sie würden auch in
diesem Fall wo nun massiv zivile
Bevölkerung und zwar ganz bewusst
bombardiert werden keine Ausnahme machen
für deutsche Waffen aber für andere
Länder schon haben wir verstanden und
begrüßen jetzt um mit nuripur in Bonn
kurz vor dem Parteitag der Grünen der in
dieser Stadt stattfindet wir sind mit
ihnen verbunden Henry jetzt gibt es
heute einen lesen wir aus den Meldungen
einen Luftabwehr ihres tslm Schirm
besser als nichts und besser als wieder
zu spät
die Systeme die wir liefern retten
Menschenleben
ihres Tee ist das perfekte Beispiel
dafür mit Iris t kann man ja Großstadt
schützen genau gegen diese Raketen und
ich muss jetzt zugeben dass ich mich
jetzt mehrfach aufrege über das was
Gregor Gysi gesagt hat erstens ist die
Geschichte alle sollen helfen auch mit
Waffen nur wir nicht ist die klassische
Nummer ich will auf keinen Fall
irgendwie Dinge machen die mir die Hände
schmutzig machen zweitens ich weiß nicht
was das jetzt mir Saudi Arabien zu tun
hat und wo wir jetzt da Geld dran
verdienen es ist zentral dass wir jetzt
der Ukraine einfach die Dinge geben die
sie brauchen und zwar mit großer
Geschwindigkeit und drittens dieses wir
reden über alles wir reden über alles
wir können auch über Saudi Arabien
sprechen das entscheidende Frau Illner
und dann reden wir über Saudi Arabien
aber sieht entziehen sich der
Verantwortung beim Thema Ukraine und
dann auch noch die ganze Zeit sagen ja
wir müssen jetzt mal über das andere
reden und alles andere ist wichtig
spielt genau dem in die Hände was wenn
heute ist gerade genannt hat
Putins Spiel dass wir alles dass das wir
die Geduld verlieren und genau das
dürfen wir nicht zulassen und wir müssen
uns einfach darauf einrichten und ich
weiß dass wenn man in Twitter Länge
grundsätzlich denken mag dass das
vielleicht ein bisschen anstrengend ist
aber das was gerade die Teilmobilmachung
mit sich bringt ist eine Vorbereitung
auch von sehr langen Krieg seitens
Russlands und wenn wir jetzt einfach
sagen jetzt haben wir aber keine Lust
mehr und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich mal
zum Ende kommen und jetzt Ukraine bewegt
euch ist das genau das Spiel von Putin
und das dürfen wir nicht zulassen wir
sind in der Situation peter Neumann ist
heute bei uns Sicherheitsexperte
terrorismusexperte in der Situation dass
die
europäischen Staaten manche europäischen
Staaten andere in der Welt den deutschen
den Vorwurf machen zwischen den Stühlen
zu sein und auf zu viel Rücksicht
genommen zu haben besonders vorsichtig
zu sein ist das doppelt unangenehm für
Deutschland in dieser Situation weil man
uns immer unterstellt dass wir eine
zweite Agenda haben oder
Muskel haben also schon richtig dass man
Deutschland auch wegen der
russland-politik in der Vergangenheit
etwas misstraut und ich glaube es ist
nicht einfacher geworden durch das
Zögern am Anfang dieses Konflikts wo es
ganz lange gedauert hat bis Deutschland
letztlich die Waffen geliefert hat die
es jetzt liefert nun wird ja immer
argumentiert ja wir liefern ja jetzt
aber ich glaube durch dieses Zögern und
Zaudern am Anfang ist ganz viel
Vertrauen verloren gegangen und
Vertrauen dauert es es dauert sehr lange
Vertrauen aufzubauen aber man kann es
sehr sehr schnell verlieren und genau
das ist passiert die Ukraine die
ukrainische Regierung traut Deutschland
nicht aber das hat uns jetzt nicht
unbedingt mehr Vertrauen von Putin
eingebracht also das war ein Fehler wir
liefern jetzt wir sollen auch weiter
liefern es ist wichtig dass wir das tun
aber wir haben glaube ich am Anfang
dieses Konfliktes viel Vertrauen
verspielt und in Bezug auf das was wir
jetzt tun
versuchen wir da etwas wiedergut zu
machen in ihren Augen oder ist das ein
Einlösen von versprechen die wir sowieso
gaben das ist richtig und ich glaube
auch zum Beispiel bei diesem
Luftabwehrsystem was um mit nuripur
erwähnt hat ist es zum Beispiel auch
wichtig dass noch mehr passiert wir
haben jetzt ein System geliefert aber zu
diesem System nur 48 Raketen also wenn
Russland tatsächlich angreift dann kann
dieses System eine Großstadt schützen
aber eben nur für einen halben Tag das
heißt man kann nicht nur das System
liefern man muss auch die Raketen
liefern die dazu notwendig sind damit
dieses System funktioniert wir wollen ja
fragen ist das eine Eskalation ja es ist
eine Eskalation und wie kommt man dann
aus ihrer aus heute auch omidori pur hat
der Bundeskanzler angekündigt dass es
einen raketenschutzschirm geben soll
zusammen mit 14 anderen europäischen
Ländern das ist wenn man auch da ein
bisschen genauer hinschaut für 2025
annotiert und damit nicht mehr als
erstmal ein frommer Wunsch
es ist notwendig das Signal zu senden
und es ist richtig dass wir schneller
und besser werden müssen aber ihr
ästhese sind genau das perfekte Beispiel
wir haben der Ukraine 10 versprochen
aber die gibt es halt noch nicht deshalb
muss man schauen dass dass man so
schnell wie möglich auch welche bekommt
die müssen erst teilweise gebaut werden
und der Grund dafür wiederum ist das
einfach in der richtig teilweise weil
man damit nicht gerechnet hat teilweise
weil auch wirklich die Bundeswehr
bekanntermaßen ja von von zahlreichen
schwarzen Verteidigungsministern die
letzten Jahre heruntergewirtschaftet
worden ist aber jetzt glaube ich ist das
entscheidende zu schauen was die Ukraine
braucht und was machbar ist und dann
nicht die ganze Zeit diskutieren ob das
jetzt aus dem Beständen der Bundeswehr
kommt oder die Industrie oder woher
sondern liefern was was gebraucht wird
weil jetzt gilt es auch um Zeit jetzt
geht es darum Geschwindigkeit jetzt geht
es um Geschwindigkeit eben vor dem
Winter katrin hat gestern mit dem
ukrainischen Präsidenten ein Interview
geführt Katrin da sehen wir noch mal ein
paar Bilder von ihnen und diesem
Gespräch welchen Eindruck hatten sie
ja ich hatte den Eindruck das Präsident
selensky sein Land hier auch an einem
klaren Wendepunkt sieht allerdings sieht
er die Lage nicht mehr so düster wie zu
Anfang also er hat im Gespräch mit mir
gesagt dass er mittlerweile schon sieht
dass das westliche Bündnis also NATO
auch die Europäer verstanden haben um
was es in der Ukraine geht was ihn mit
großer Sorge erfüllt das dass die
Europäer sich doch von Putins
Atomwaffen Drohungen sehr einschüchtern
lassen und er sagt es gibt immer noch
Teile in Europa die bis heute nicht
verstanden haben das mit Putin der Weg
über Diplomatie und den Dialog und das
zurück Rücken nicht funktioniert sondern
das einzige was als Strategie aus seiner
Perspektive funktioniert ist einfach
zusammen zu stehen und harte Haltung zu
zeigen was ich auch sehr interessant
fand es wurde ja angesprochen das
Verhältnis zu Deutschland und wie
kritisch die Ukraine Deutschland sieht
den Eindruck hatte ich zu Beginn des
Krieges auch also da habe ich auch einen
sehr verbitterten selensky zu Anfang
erlebt in Butcher zum Beispiel der
gesagt hat Angela Merkel müsste mal
hierhin kommen und sich angucken was das
Resultat der deutschen Politik der
piecenden Politik mit Russland ist jetzt
hat er sich im Gespräch ganz anders
geäußert er hat ich habe ihn zum
Beispiel gefragt wer ist Ihnen denn nah
wer waren denn zum Beispiel als hier in
Kiew die Raketen einschlugen die ersten
mit denen sie geredet haben und da sagt
er es gab drei Politiker mit denen ich
sofort kommuniziert habe das waren duda
im manuellen macron und Olaf Scholz Olaf
den er sogar beim Vornamen nennt und er
hat gesagt dass sich in den Beziehungen
deutlich etwas verändert hat und dass er
sieht dass Deutschland auch mittlerweile
verstanden hat um was es in der Ukraine
geht und dass er sich wünscht dass
dieses Verhältnis ja weiter so gut
bleibt also das fand ich doch sehr
bemerkenswert gucken wir noch mal auf
das was er jüngst sagte seine Aussagen
über mögliche Präventivschläge des
Westens gegen Russland die hat er sehr
schnell relativiert dennoch die Frage
war er in ihren Augen ist die Ukraine in
ihren Augen momentan einfach auch sehr
Sieges gewiss möglicherweise zu
siegesgewiss
das ist sehr schwierig zu sagen weil das
hängt natürlich ein bisschen auch davon
ab mit wem man spricht ich würde sagen
wenn man sich jetzt die Regierung
anguckt ich habe nicht das Gefühl dass
silensky siegesgewiss ist ich habe das
Gefühl also in diesem Gespräch dass er
sehr sehr groß die Bedrohung für sein
Land einschätzt dass diese
raketenschläger auch ihm noch mal klar
gemacht haben und der Militärführung wie
verletzlich die Ukraine ist dass diese
Erfolge am Boden die das ukrainische
militärjahr erzielt hat eine Sache sind
und dass die Devise der Rückeroberung
vom kompletten Territorium das besetzt
ist durch Russland durchaus jetzt
realistischer scheint aber die Ukraine
bereitet sich schon auf einen harten
weiteren Krieg vor und auf menschliche
Opfer und das das hatte ich den Eindruck
besorgt ihn schon sehr also selensky ist
schon klar und der Militärführung auch
dass dieser nicht von heute auf morgen
zu beenden ist
dass auf jeden Fall die Ukraine darauf
angewiesen ist dass der Westen weiter
unter seiner harten Position der ja
jetzt im Moment zeigt die Ukraine weiter
unterstützt also Sieges gewiss würde ich
nicht sagen aber optimistisch in der
Einschätzung was die Unterstützung des
Westens angeht wir sind noch mal bei der
Frage an Ben Hodges dass das war
interessant dass diese Idee von selensky
eben zu präventivschlägen zu diesem
preampitive strikes zu greifen von ihm
selber dann relativiert wurde und
abgemildert wurde glauben Sie dass das
aus eigenem Antrieb geschehen ist oder
war hat es auch Druck gegeben auf ihn
er ist der Präsident eines Landes das im
Augenblick massiv angegriffen wird
er und seine Mitbürger MitbürgerInnen
sind jeden Tag der Gefahr des Todes
ausgesetzt und deswegen tun sie alles
was sie können in dem Einhalt zu
gebieten und auch um zu gewinnen und ich
glaube schon dass er zuversichtlich ist
dass sie eines Tages gewinnen werden er
sieht die Widerstandskraft ihres eigenen
Militärs und ihre eigenen Bevölkerung
erkennt die andere Seite und er weiß
auch dass auf der russischen Seite
eigentlich kein Wille zum Kampf
vorhanden ist und die russische
Bevölkerung diesen Krieg nicht wünscht
das heißt bei diesem Krieg geht es auch
um einen Krieg zwischen dem Willen des
Gremlins und des Westens und das ist der
letzte Winter wo Russland ist noch
schaffen kann die europäische und
Wirtschaft zu beeinträchtigen das ist
der letzte Winter wo Russland auch die
Energielieferung nach Europa
unterbrechen kann die Russen haben ihre
gaskarte wenn Sie so wollen das Ass aus
dem Ärmel viel zu früh gespielt
Deutschland hat sich jetzt signifik
sowohl physisch als auch psychologisch
und Präsident selensky weiß das
wenn wir jetzt also mit ihnen
zusammenhalten dann wird schon im
nächsten Sommer wahrscheinlich Russland
zurückgedrängt worden sein auf die
Linien des 23 Februar ich glaube sogar
dass bis zum nächsten Sommer die
krimheitinsel wieder befreit sein kann
absolut und dafür werden sie das
Potenzial haben dafür werden sie die
Kraft haben weil es auch im Interesse
des Westens ist das sogar die Krim
zurückerobert wird
im Interesse des Westens das souveräne
Länder europäischer
Länder auch natürlich geschützt werden
das ist im Interesse des bestens und
natürlich
hat die Ukraine jetzt im Augenblick
nicht unbedingt ein Problem mit der Zahl
der Soldaten sie haben 700.000 Leute in
den Uniform und das ist eine sehr viel
bessere Situation als auf der russischen
Seite aber es ist auch ganz wichtig
maybrit dass auch die Chinesen diesen
Konflikt mitverfolgen und wenn die
Chinesen sehen dass der Westen nicht
zusammenhalten kann auch wenn es ein
wirtschaftlichen Druck gibt und wenn sie
es nicht schaffen ein ziemlich schwaches
Russland zu besiegen dann werden die
Chinesen sich nicht besonders
beeindrucken lassen von den Dingen die
wir über Taiwan sagen oder das
Südchinesische Meer das ist so
interessant peter Neumann da sagt nicht
nur Ben Hodges sondern ich weiß dass ich
ihn zurecht zitiere auch mit Nuri pur
die Ukraine kann diesen Krieg gewinnen
und dann stellen wir uns vor und sie
kann sogar schaffen die Krim
zurückzuerobern und dann stellen wir uns
vor dass sich der Verlierer Putin träumt
ja und da sage ich da ist mir die
Debatte in Deutschland ein bisschen zu
einfach also es gibt zwei
unterschiedliche Positionen die glaube
ich ziemlich extrem sind und wo jede
Seite die andere Hälfte des Arguments
jeweils ausblendet es gibt zwei
imperative der eine Imperativ ist das
was general hodgeist gerade beschrieben
hat dass die Idee dass Putin diesen
Konflikt nicht gewinnen darf dass er
einen Preis dafür bezahlen muss dass er
diese Aggression begangen hat dass er
bestraft werden muss auch im Hinblick
darauf dass er möglicherweise wenn er
nicht bestraft wird andere Dinge tut
oder dass die Chinesen merken dass es
einfach ist den besten zu besuchen das
ist die eine das ist der eine Realität
der eine Imperativ auf der anderen Seite
wissen wir dass wir im Prinzip im Krieg
mit Russland sind Russland ist nach wie
vor ein wichtiger geopolitischer AK
zeigen wie wir diese Woche gesehen haben
kann Russland auch eskalieren und die
eskalationsschritt die wir gesehen haben
diese Woche das sind nur die ersten
Eskalation Schritte am Ende dieser
Eskalationsspirale steht möglicherweise
auch der Einsatz von taktischen
Nuklearwaffen ich bin nicht der
Auffassung dass man sich von dieser
Angst davor treiben lassen soll aber
jeder Experte und jeder Expertin jeder
Politiker und jede Politikerin erkennen
doch an dass das eine strategische
Kalkulation beeinflussen muss also wir
haben auf der einen Seite wir müssen den
Putin schlagen auf der anderen Seite
sind wir in einem Konflikt mit Russland
der möglicherweise enorme geopolitische
Konsequenzen haben können und Fall ein
Weltkrieg werden kann möglicherweise
aber so weit möchte ich gar nicht gehen
aber ist auf jeden Fall was ich sagen
möchte ist das ist ein komplexes
strategisches Terrain es ist nicht
einfach und es ist nicht so einfach zu
sagen wir sollen da raus oder wir sollen
den Ukrain alles geben was sie möchten
es ist komplex und wir müssen da viele
Dinge berücksichtigen die die Sache
gefährlicher würden sie sogar so also
würden sie soweit gehen wie General
Hodges und sagen das Ziel muss auch das
Ziel des Westens muss sein dass die
Ukraine die Krim zurückholen können oder
sagen Sie der 24.2 des Jahres 22 ist
also ich finde es wichtig dass die
Ukraine so viel von ihrer
territorialen Integrität zurückerobert
wie es möglich ist ohne gleichzeitig
einen riesigen geopolitischen Konflikt
auszulösen und jetzt kann man darüber
diskutieren wann ist dieser Punkt
erreicht und diese Diskussion haben wir
bisher nicht gehabt wir sagen wir wollen
dass die dass die Ukraine gewinnt aber
meine Frage ist dann wenn das ein
Student mir sagen würde würde ich sagen
definiere gewinnen was ist denn ein
Gewinn ja und das ist schwierig ja wir
sind frau Klein bei einer interessanten
Frage wie schätzt die russland-expertin
diese neuerliche Drohung von Vladimir
Putin das macht er ja nicht zum ersten
mal mit einer
taktischen nuklearenantworte ein
vielleicht ganz kurz noch dazu ich
stimme zu das ist strategisch komplex
und es ist auch so dass es sich
zeitlicher verändert es gibt einen
Friedens also ein Plan von silensky vom
29.03 indem man noch davon spricht dass
über die Krim 15 Jahre verhandelt werden
kann Putin hat diese Tür für diese
Verhandlungen aber zugemacht in dem
Moment in dem er proklamiert annektiert
hat in dem Moment kann die ukrainische
Führung fast gar nicht anders mehr
sondern hat festgelegt jetzt geht dieser
Plan letztendlich nicht mehr also es ist
auch in der zeitlichen Dimension es
verändert sich immer wieder zu der
nuklearen Drohung ich glaube die hat
eine innenpolitisches Publikum in der
Situation an der Russland Niederlagen
einfährt ist es wichtig nach innen zu
demonstrieren dass man noch mehr hat
dass man siegessicher ist und es hat
natürlich eine Funktion nach außen
Ängste und Sorgen im Westen
hervorzurufen dass man die Ukraine nicht
weiter unterstützt jetzt ist es so dass
es politisch keinen Sinn für die
russische Führung machen Sinn
verschiedene Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen
das würde all diejenigen die Russland
noch stillschweigend unterstützen oder
zumindest neutral sind bei diesem
Tabubruch letztendlich von Russland
wegbringen das macht in der Hinsicht
eigentlich keinen Sinn sondern das ist
das Spiel mit der Angst im Moment auch
wenn wir nicht hundert Prozent
ausschließen können dass die
Rationalität dieses Regimes eines Tages
eine solche wird es sie so etwas
einsetzt einmal im Moment sehe ich das
wirklich als das Spiel mit unseren
Ängsten um uns von der Unterstützung der
Ukraine abhalten zu lassen weil wir die
Eskalation eben Christoph Heusgen der
Chef der Münchner Sicherheitsberater
Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz ehemaliger
Sicherheitsberater von Angela Merkel
sagt diese Drohung ist für die Europäer
und besonders für die deutschen warum
denken Sie warum denkt Putin dass wir
noch viel mehr als unsere Nachbarn uns
davon beeindrucken lassen
von dieser Drohung ich glaube es wirkt
nicht nur in Deutschland es wirkt auch
drüber hinaus aber wir sind natürlich
ein Land das eine andere strategische
Kultur hat als beispielsweise Frankreich
Großbritannien oder auch Finnland die
eine lange sehr konfrontative Beziehung
auch mit Russland hinter sich haben
gelernte haben eine andere Vorbereitung
zu treffen für so einen Fall
beispielsweise was die Ausrüstung mit
schutzkellern und so weiter anbelangt
die sind vorbereitet da lassen sich hier
in der Hinsicht diese Ängste nicht so
leicht spielen und es ist natürlich
Deutschland ist ein Schlüsselland das
dürfen wir nicht vergessen Schlüssel
dann zur Aufrechterhaltung der
Sanktionen Schlüsselland um die
Russlandpolitik der EU und auch der NATO
mitzubestimmen Frage zu nach Bonn jetzt
gab es heute interessanterweise eben
auch von Immanuel macron dem
französischen präsidenteneinlassungen
Möglichkeiten zu suchen
ja also auch eine politische Lösung zu
nicht zu vergessen und weiter zu
verhandeln und nicht in jedem Fall auch
auf eine selbst Einsatz von taktischen
Raketen wiederum auch mit einer
taktischen nuklearen Antwort zu
reagieren sind wir die einzigen die sich
da beeindrucken lassen haben wir da die
Franzosen vielleicht länger und sowieso
unserer Seite was denken sie
ich teile sehr dass die sorgen vor allem
Atomschlag der Russen berechtigt sind
ich teile aber auch sehr dass wir uns
davon nicht lähmen lassen dürfen es mag
sein dass in Deutschland die Diskussion
darum eine andere Höhe hat man kann
darüber diskutieren woran es liegt kann
auch daran liegen dass Deutschland als
quasi zentraler Frontstaat des Kalten
Krieges nach Jahrzehnten der massiven
nuklearen Bedrohung und es wird ja
manchmal ausgeblendet wie nah wir daran
waren teilweise auch in Fulda gab eine
andere Sensitivität hat aber es ist ja
richtig und berechtigt sehr sehr genau
hinzuschauen
ich wenn ich in einem Satz die Frage von
peter Neumann für seine Studenten
beantworten darf gewinnen heißt für die
Ukraine des hier Land zurückgewinnen
nicht mehr aber auch nicht weniger und
nicht mehr bedeutet auch nicht dass
jetzt die die Russen jetzt irgendwie
kaputt geschossen werden es geht darum
dass die russische Führung auch die
Grenzen des Landes akzeptiert
interessanterweise
anderen Länder akzeptiert auch der
Ukraine auch wenn ich noch Einsatz sagen
darf zu zu macrondebatte es ist
vollkommen richtig natürlich jeden
Strang zu nehmen der irgendwie nach nach
Erfolg aussehen kann um Gespräche zu
führen
nicht nur ich Leute wie ich haben die
letzten acht Jahre sehr viele Gespräche
geführt von der mit der russischen Seite
die waren weitgehend fruchtlos trotzdem
hätten wir die Gespräche auch weiter
fortgesetzt es ist zur Zeit die
russische Seite diese Gespräche nicht
erwidert und jede verhandlungsinitiative
Richtung russland hat eine hat zwei
Bedingungen einmal dass die russische
Seite irgendwie auch fernes walten lässt
und zweitens ist dass das natürlich mit
den Betroffenen und es sind die
ukraineren Ukraine abgesprochen sein
muss wir sind Gregor Gysi bei der Frage
wie groß ist unsere Angst die Linke hat
dazu also wie groß ist die Angst der
Menschen wie sehr spielt Wladimir Putin
damit die Linke hat unter anderem zu
Demonstrationen aufgerufen ist ihnen
entschuldigung wenn ich das so
persönlich frage ist ihnen ist den mit
Demonstranten das Schicksal der Ukrainer
da egal sagen sie hauptsache der Krieg
ist zu Ende und das Gas wird wieder
billig nein also das sind nämlich kurz
drei vier Bemerkungen machen erstens
was ich vorhin mit Saudi-Arabien meint
das was ganz anderes wir sind der
fünftgrößte Waffenexporteur der Welt und
das bei unserer Geschichte verdienen wir
an jedem Krieg mit und das finde ich
falsch ja was ich auch sagen will ich
glaube dass der Putin den Beginn seines
Ende des eingeleitet hat da bin ich
ziemlich sicher er wird das Ganze
vielleicht vorübergehend überstehen aber
nicht dauerhaft da bin ich aus sicher
drittens hier geht es um soziale
Proteste und da stehen wir vor der Wahl
entweder überlassen wir der AFD die
Straßen und Plätze und sagt organisiert
alle sozialen Proteste in Ost und West
oder die linke kämpft um die sozialen
Proteste da geht es ja nur darum dass
die Leute wirklich nicht frieren müssen
in der Lage sind die erhöhten Preise für
Lebensmittel für Gast für viele haben
auch Ölheizung an die es noch gar nicht
gedacht worden zum Beispiel ganze
Gruppen werden vergessen zum Beispiel
Menschen im privater Insolvenz würde ich
jetzt alles gar nicht erläutern und das
ist auch wichtig und richtig dass das
die Linke macht lassen Sie mich noch
etwas sagen weil so viel fliegen hier
gesprochen worden ist ich glaube ich
kann mich erinnern aber ich glaube beide
Seiten können in dem Sinne nicht siegen
und deshalb wäre dass man schnell zu
einem Button Stillstand kommt ist ganz
wichtig dabei muss man im Völkerrecht
immer folgendes unterscheiden es gibt
faktische zur Kenntnisnahme und
juristische Anerkennung juristische
Anerkennung kann es nie geben aber wenn
sich die Ukraine und Russland durch wen
auch immer auf irgendein Kompromiss
damit endlich die Waffen schweigen
einigen sollten haben wir das zu
akzeptieren wir können da nicht sagen
ihr müsst weiter kämpfen oder so und das
zweite was mir auch wichtig ist die
Verurteilung des Völkerrechts für ewigen
Krieges und auch der
völkerrechtswidrigen Vereinnahmung von
terreströmen muss bleiben und ich will
jetzt nicht auf das Kosovo zu sprechen
kommen aber damals habe ich gesagt wie
falsch das ist wenn man den
völkerrechtswidrigen Weg geht und dass
das Schule machen wird und jetzt sind
wir in einer noch schlimmeren Situation
wissen wir was mich vor einer am meisten
stört vielleicht bleiben wir erstmal
letzter Satz okay
gestört im Kalten Krieg ich war so froh
dass wir den überwunden haben weil die
Welt stabiler als heute es ist doch
gerade zu absurd aber so ist es also man
darf ja immer noch darüber froh sein
dass die Welt nicht mehr in Blöcke
geteilt ist damit ist aus dem Politik
aber automatisch ein bisschen komplexer
und gegebenenfalls auch anstrengender in
diesem Fall nicht weniger brutal sie
sind Herr Neumann aber ja noch mal bei
der Frage ist das aufzulösen kann man
beides wenn man jetzt die Signale
versucht zu deuten
Putin signalisiert G20 da kann man sich
vielleicht treffen
Joe Biden sagt ja aber nicht zu den
Themen zu denen Herr Putin reden will
vielleicht über was anderes und auf der
anderen Seite zu sagen also gibt es in
ihren Augen an irgendeiner Stelle ist
meine Frage ein Gesprächsangebot dass
wir vorgestern noch nicht momentan nicht
was ich noch sagen wollte ist es kann
uns wenn wir über den Sieg der Ukraine
sprechen und ich gebe natürlich um mit
nuripur Recht natürlich sollen die
gewinnen und natürlich sollen die
äteritorium zurückkriegen aber wir als
Westen müssen uns darüber legen was ist
zum Beispiel die Konsequenz in Russland
wenn die Konsequenz in Russland ist dass
wir in Russland Staatszerfall und Chaos
haben oder möglicherweise das eine an
die Macht kommt der noch
ultra-nationalistischer ist dann ist das
nicht unbedingt
positives Ergebnis geopolitisch weil es
noch größere
Zerwürfnisse produzieren kann was die
Verhandlungen angeht glaube ich das wird
noch eine ganze Weile dauern ich bin da
nicht so optimistisch wie er Gysi weil
für Verhandlungen brauchen Sie gar nicht
brauchen Sie
zwei Parteien die miteinander sprechen
wollen und wir wissen auf ukrainischer
Seite wenn selensky heute sagen würde
ich mache ein Kompromiss wäre er morgen
nicht mehr Präsident und auf russischer
Seite haben wir ja schon so viele
Versuche gehabt herr Gysi ja angefangen
mit Israel Türkei herr Scholz
telefoniert Herma Korn telefoniert Herr
nehammer aus Österreich ist nach
Gefahren alle betteln sie ihn an sprich
doch und es ist kein es gibt kein
interessant als Vermittler verständigen
Stadt auf Scholz und macron was sich
viel logisch finde selbst wenn es
schwierig ist ich glaube einfach dass so
viel versucht war an jeder Ecke hat
jemand hat fast jeder versucht dieses
diese Gesprächsbereitschaft von Putin zu
bekommen und er hat es bei an jedem
Punkt abgelehnt das einzige was wir
jetzt haben ist ein Angebot von Herrn
lavrov das möglicherweise Herr Putin
bereit ist mit den Amerikanern zu
sprechen über die Köpfe der Ukraine
hinweg und das ist natürlich nicht
akzeptabel meine Bemerkung dass diese
dieses Angebot war zu lesen und nicht
nur zwischen den Zeilen sondern das gab
es wirklich und es schließt natürlich
die Frage an eigentlich suchen die
Russen die Auseinandersetzung oder das
gentlemanagement mit den USA das ist
auch keine besonders neue these Joe
Biden hat sich zweimal geäußert in den
letzten sagen einmal am Sonntag und
einmal am Dienstag und diesen Äußerungen
hat nicht nur Vladimir Putin zugehört
die Welt horcht auf als Joe Biden warnt
Putin scherzt nicht wenn er vom Einsatz
taktischer Nuklearwaffen spricht zum
ersten Mal seit der Kubakrise haben wir
es mit einer direkten Drohung mit
Atomwaffen zu tun
ich denke nicht dass es möglich ist
taktische Atomwaffen einzusetzen ohne
dass es am Ende ein Armageddon eine
Katastrophe gibt
beiden ergänzt am Dienstag
ich glaube nicht dass er das tun wird
ich halte es für unverantwortlich dass
er darüber spricht dass ein Staatschef
einer der größten Atommächte sagt er
könnte eine taktische Atomwaffe
einsetzen was ich sagen wollte war dass
dies zu einem schrecklichen Ergebnis
führen könnte
wenn heute sie müssen uns das Übersetzen
helfen Dolmetschen helfen auf der einen
Seite hält er ihn für einen rationalen
Akteur und sagt Putin Scherz nicht und
auf der anderen Seite spielt er mit
dieser biblischen Schlacht Armageddon
und warnt vor einem Weltuntergang
ich glaube dass mein Präsident
hier dem Präsidenten der Russischen
Föderation übermitteln wollte dass wir
ihn ernst nehmen ich glaube Putin
beschwert sich häufiger ist der besten
ihn nicht ernst nimmt und Präsident
beiden wollte klarmachen dass wir die
Bedrohung ernst nehmen das war weshalb
er diese Metapher mit Armageddon
verwendet hat aber er wollte auch an
Präsident Putin übermitteln dass wir es
auch ernst meinen mit den möglichen
Konsequenzen wenn er sich so
verkalkuliert und glaubt dass er eine
Nuklearwaffe einsetzen könnte ich glaube
dass sie das im Kreml durchaus verstehen
ich glaube dass sie dort wissen dass
Präsident beiden es ernst meint und ich
glaube das Wort auf ganz vielen
verschiedenen Ebenen kommuniziert
offiziell inoffiziell und ich glaube das
auch andere Länder das dem Kreml zu
verstehen geben das ist für Sie vorbei
wäre wenn Sie diesen fürchterlichen
Fehler machen würden und ich glaube dass
die Menschen um Präsident Putin herum
auch darüber denken wie das Leben nach
ihm weitergehen wird und das ist
vielleicht das einzige wo ich Ihnen
heute abend zustimme nämlich dass das
vielleicht der Anfang des Endes von
Präsident Putin ist und ich glaube dass
die Menschen um ihn herum jetzt
vielleicht anfangen darüber nachzudenken
wie das Leben wohl aussehen würde wenn
er eine Nuklearwaffe einsetzen würde
dann kann ich es vergessen in Belgravia
zu leben oder woanders zu leben ich kann
all diese Sachen vergessen wenn wir ihn
nicht abhalten können diese
Fehlkalkulation durchzuziehen und ich
glaube mein Präsident war hier sehr
deutlich wird auf die Kubakrise
verwiesen geschieht absolut geschieht
das war sie so gefährlich war oder weil
sie gut so gut ausging
dass die Kuba-Krise
natürlich ein ganz entscheidender
Augenblick war ich bin alt genug um mir
dessen noch bewusst zu sein und jetzt
befinden wir uns in einer anderen
Situation
denn es gibt die Möglichkeit taktische
Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen
in der Kubakrise ging es um strategische
Nuklearwaffen und das ist eine ganz
andere Art von Gefahr bei einer
taktischen Nuklearwaffe
die lässt sich auf ganz verschiedene Art
und Weise einsetzen das ist also eine
andere Gefährdungslage ich glaube das
ist trotzdem noch unwahrscheinlich ist
und bleibt denn einen taktische
Nuklearwaffe da muss man die gesamte
Befehlskette vom Generalstab mit
einbeziehen und an vielen Stellen werden
da Entscheidung getroffen und ich
bezweifle dass sie das tun würden
sie müssen sich entscheiden dann bringe
ich beides unter in der einen frage ich
wollte wissen
ob man sich darauf verlassen kann dass
es eine geheime Diplomatie zwischen
Russland und den USA gibt damit eine
rote Linie nicht überschritten wird sie
tatsächlich zur Weltkrieg führen könnte
und diese von dem ich sonst nicht viel
halte recht hat wenn er sagt falls die
USA und Russland ist wollen gibt es
einen Waffenstillstand sonst nicht der
lässt auch die Ukraine aus
wir sind sollt er nur antworten oder wie
ich ordne jetzt mal ganz kurz die Frage
aber die zwei Fragen und sie sind
interessant und deshalb spielte ich auf
Kuba an es hat immer diese back-channels
gegeben in vergleichbaren Krisen der
Welt in dem Fall ist es offensichtlich
Putins großes Interesse von den
Amerikanern nicht nur anerkannt zu
werden sondern das Gespräch mit beiden
zu finden die werden das nicht
persönlich tun aber es gibt vielleicht
diese back-channels jedenfalls wird
darüber spekuliert noch mal die Frage an
sie glauben Sie Herr Neumann dass das
unter der Hand existiert und geschieht
und glauben Sie dass dieser Satz die
Ukraine muss es am Ende entscheiden
eigentlich ein falscher Satz ist es wird
woanders entschieden also das Ernte ist
ja diese diese Kanäle existieren
natürlich